tout est affaire de décors changer de
lit changer de corps à quoi bon puisque
c'est encore moi qui moi même me
travailler
noah qui veut très les papilles
boss des habits dans les bras semblables
des filles où j'ai cru trouver un pays
car léger car changeant kerlouan le
temps de révérer biencourt que faut-il
faire de mes jours que faut-il faire de
minuit
je n'avais à bord ni demain
du leparoux jeu
je passais comme la rue
je m'endormais comme le bruit que les
hommes vivent et leurs bébés au loin
les chemins
c'était un temps déraisonnable on avait
mis les morts à table on faisait des
châteaux de sable on prenait les loups
pour des chiens
tout change et de paul et des pôles
la pièce était celle où l'on drôle moi
si j'étais même albert hall ce que denis
comprend rien le ciel était gris de
nuages il y voler des oies sauvages qui
crie est la mort au passage au dessus
des maisons decker
je les voyais par la fenêtre leurs
chants triste entrée dans mon maître et
se croyait j'y reconnais c'est renner
barry argué est ce ainsi que les hommes
vivent et leurs baisers au loin du sou
dans le quartier de renzo leur entre la
sar est les casernes comme les fleurs de
la lousiane fleurissaient les simples de
lola elle avec hacker d'hirondelles sur
le canapé du bordel je venais m'allonger
près d'elle dans les rockets du piano
l'art elle était brune et blanche
ses cheveux tomber tous et angers la
semaine dimanche
elle ouvrait à tous ces braves où elle
avait des yeux de faïence
travaillait avec vaillance pour un
martyr de mayence qui n'en est jamais
revenu reste ainsi que les hommes vivent
et bunge et au loin
mais il est d'autres soldats cent mille
et la nuit montrent les civils europe et
de e-mails à taissy dollars quittent on
ira bientôt encore un verre de liqueur
ce python avril à chaleur eau peut
toujours que dans ton coeur
dragons plonge à son couteau reste que
les hommes vivent ils au baiser au loin
les suit
comme des soleils révolue
servat à la paire de route motards rsa
complaisamment